[Applaudissements]
le légendaire groupe suédois abba est de
retour benny bionne en ont fait
l'annoncé aujourd'hui durant un
événement en direct de londres et
diffusée sur youtube
ils ont dévoilé 10 nouvelles chansons
qui seront réunis sur un album intitulé
voyage
grand retour attendu pendant quatre
décennies en plus du nouveau disque abx
a également annoncé la création d'un
nouveau spectacle qui mettra en vedette
sur scène et des hologrammes des quatre
membres du groupe qui sont désormais
septuagénaire des personnages qu'ils
baptisent des abatteurs et qui ont été
écrits par une équipe de plus de 500
artistes et experts en effets spéciaux
les concerts seront présentés à londres
à compter du 27 mai à la barre rina les
nouvelles salles de 3000 places conçue
spécialement pour accueillir le concert
les membres d'abba explique qu'une
guerre commencé à germer en 2018
lorsqu'ils ont décidé d'enregistrer du
nouveau titre constatant que la magie
continue d'opérer ils ont décidé de
faire tout un album
au cours de leur carrière ils ont vendu
près de 400 millions d'albums à travers
le monde obtenu 17 numéro un et récolter
chaque semaine plus de 16 millions d'
écoute sur les plateformes en continu
sans compter la comédie musicale et les
film mamma mia inspiré des chansons
d'abba et qui ont été de grands succès
la magie d'abba continue d'opérer et si
on se fie aux premières réactions cette
réunion d'abba devrait faire un tabac
ici nabi alexandre chartier radio canada
montréal